on our quest for a drive technology
that's both environmental and economical
we tried out the Leon St 1.40 GI by sea
at it has a bi valent or bi fuel engine
meaning it runs on both natural and
normal gas the tanks are under the car
and inside the trunk floor one holds
some 15 kilos of natural gas the other
takes 50 litres of gasoline for a
combined range of 1,300 kilometres under
the hood is the 1.4 liter engine which
after some technical adjustments runs on
both fuel types
the TGI delivers 81 kilowatts of power
see at rates fuel consumption at three
and a half kilos per hundred kilometers
emitting less than 100 grams of co2 per
kilometer these numbers sound easy on
the environment and the white at the
current price of one euro four cents per
kilo of natural gas that adds up to just
under three euros seventy four hundred
kilometers power reviewer mantis
concedes that with this engine
the Leon St is no rocket 81 kilowatts
are enough to keep up with traffic and
even manage an occasional sprint as long
as there's natural gas in the tank that
bi valent Leon's engine will use it
instead of the gasoline Malthus assures
potential drivers that they needn't
worry about complicated switchovers once
the natural gas is used up the car
automatically changes to gasoline power
but you want to get to a natural gas
fueling station as soon as possible
since driving on normal fuel costs or
money when the tanks empty we head to a
CNG or compressed natural gas station
just how economical is the Leon in
practice and is it really as green as
the manufacturers figures indicate and
just over a euro per kilogram the
advantage over fossil fuels is obvious
but do drivers really save that much on
the road
yet filling the tank with natural gas is
almost the same process as with normal
fuel down below are two receptacles one
for premium gasoline and one for natural
gas you just take the natural gas nozzle
connect it under doc press the button
and wait until the tank is filled polish
in Germany it costs about 16 and a half
euros to fill the tank with natural gas
hint a meter when the nozzle is
disconnected there's a little hiss and
then you're done the spa's ocean then
there's a little surprise once the
natural gas tank is full this little
green indicator in the tachometer shows
the car is switched back it displays a
range of 260 kilometres on natural gas
that's considerably less than what Sam
promises which was a range of some 400
kilometres on natural gas for a total
range of 1,300 kilometres together with
gasoline power this is where the theory
diverges from the practice it's slightly
disappointing what that Elizabeth mattis
has no serious complaints about the
Seattle Eon St the suspension is well
balanced the engine is free revving
without a guzzling gas and the
workmanship is high-quality but who are
the buyers for this car there aren't
that many natural gas stations in Europe
need one on your way to work for example
and for longer trips the driver has to
plan the route in advance so it passes
close to a natural gas station Lange
father the mid denied the gas tanks tell
me to write biggest
in our test the alternative fuel cost
nearly six euros forty per hundred
kilometers but the small tank means
frequent refueling stops and the
additional eighteen hundred euro cost
over the gasoline powered Leon has to be
covered before it starts saving anything
you